اتكلم كثير عن الغزو عن المحاولات
الدبلوماسيه اللي قام بها العراق لتجنب
لتجريب العراق الحرب
وانه القياده نزلت جهود كبيره او بالاخص
وزير الخارجيه والجهد الدبلوماسي العراقي
لكن كانت امريكا مصممه وانه العراق بدل
اقصى الجهود فيما يخص موضوع التفتيش عن
استخدام المزعومه واقام الحجه لكن امريكا
كانت مصممه على غزو العراق
والخروج بهذه النتيجه اللي وصل لها الشعب
العراقي هل نقل لك عن احد المسؤولين
الكبار مثل هذه الاقوال عن ان امريكا
مصممه مهما فعل العراق نعم يعني مثلا
الخارجيه العراقيه اكدت للرئيس ان الجهد
الدبلوماسي يعني في اعلى مستوياتها لكن
الامريكان مصممين على
مصممين على غزو العراق وايضا القياده
العراقيه اكدت انه امريكا مصممه على يعني
لا مجال اجانب التقاهم مسؤولين اجانب يعني
مثلا الروس المبعوثين الروس بالاخص
والمسؤولين الاخرين ومسؤولين قاده عرب
ايضا يعني وزراء خارجيه مبعوثين عن
رؤسائهم وامرائهم اكدوا له قبل 200 قبل
2003 اكدوه لانه الجانب الامريكي مصمم على
غزو العراق
بين الرئيس وانا ذاك وبريماكوز عندما زاره
بهذا الشان كان يعني
عنده عروض معينه فكان كل ما ياتي الى
العراق يطلب الرئيس من طارق عزيز ان
يلتقوا وياه حتى يستشف السيد المرحوم طارق
عزيز ما يدور بجعبه القياده الروسيه
فسالها يعني الرئيس في احد الزيارات قال
له افترضنا اتنحيت
امريكا
يعني
يعني ما راح تغزل العراق قال لها لا تغزل
العراق بوجودك وبعدم وجودك يعني يعني
اذا كان يجنب هذا الخيار اللي انت اتيتني
به القياده الروسيه يجنب الشعب العراقي
الحديث اخر بس اذا كانوا الامريكان مثل ما
انت تاكد مصممين فلحقات مع شعبي
حملك الرئيس الراحل توصيات او توجيهات الى
المواطنين العراقيين في هذا اللقاء ما كان
ابرزها يعني سلام الى بعض الشخصيات
العراقيه والشخصيات العربيه وكان
ياكد على صمود الشعب العراقي ووقوفه صف
واحد وكان ياكد على تفويت فرصه
البرنامج اللي اتوا به الامريكان لتفريق
الشعب العراقي هذا يعني كذا وهذا كذا يعني
كطوائف
سني شيعي انه يعني لا تروحون يا الامريكان
يعني لا تسمعون الامريكان ابقوا شعب واحد
مثل ما انتم قاتلتوا ايران وانتم شعب واحد
وصف واحد وقاتلوا الامريكان بصف واحد
وبعيد عن الحقد يعني قالت لهم ضمن
المعايير القتال